the pro-democracy opposition in Hong
Kong is celebrating a landslide victory
in local elections almost 3 million
people a record 71 percent of voters
went to the polls yesterday
pro-democracy candidates won 80 percent
of the contested district council seats
this comes after months of
anti-government protests ramie Inocencio
is in Hong Kong
ramie what's the mood there good morning
pro-democracy supporters and their
winning candidates cheered online and on
the streets
some people even popped champagne
bottles when one reviled pro-beijing
legislator named Junius ho lost his seat
other pro establishment candidates who
lost even publicly bowed while accepting
defeat and that here is a major cultural
act of apology now this all comes after
the past half year of often violent
protests at times those have crippled
the city and they've even damaged its
economy but demonstrators turned to
peaceful action on Sunday at the ballot
box looked past the months of chaos and
sent a very clear message they want
democracy now the record turnout says
they're angry at their government and by
extension Beijing and the Communist
Party and they're demanding the right to
have one person one vote to elect their
chief executive now they don't have that
now but the reality of these very local
elections is that they're high on
symbolism but very low on any political
leverage for any real kind of reform and
that means that the protests that we've
been seeing over the past six months
over this international very beautiful
and very well known city are probably
set to continue Jericka I'll take this
rainy inocencia forest in Hong Kong
ramie thank you very much